This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The first proper single family house I rented in the Bay Area had a weird cabinet in the kitchen. I actually didn't notice it was weird for a long time. From the inside, it just kind of blended in with other kitchen cabinets, but one day I noticed from the outside that there were louvered vents in the wall that brought outside air into just that cabinet. After a fair amount of online digging, I discovered that this is called a California cooler. It's mostly useful for storing fresh fruits and vegetables. Cool air flows in from the lower vent,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我在湾区租下的第一栋真正意义上的独立住宅，厨房里有一个奇怪的橱柜。其实我有很长一段时间都没觉得它有什么奇怪的。从内部看，它跟其他厨房橱柜完美地融为一体，但有一天我从外面注意到，墙上有百叶通风口，能把室外的空气直接引入那个橱柜。在网上进行了一番仔细搜索后，我发现这被称为加州冷却柜。它主要用于储存新鲜水果和蔬菜。凉爽的空气从下方的通风口流入，
while warmer air flows out the upper one. Screens are usually there to keep bugs out, although I don't think mine had a screen anymore, and slats are there to deflect the rain. California coolers were pretty popular a century ago around the Bay Area. They work quite well to keep food cold, if you live within a pretty narrow
而较暖的空气则从上方的通风口流出。里面通常有纱网来挡住虫子，虽然我觉得我的那个可能早就没有纱网了，还有斜百叶用来挡雨。一个世纪前，加州冷却柜在湾区相当受欢迎。如果你住在气候温和宜人、且温度范围非常狭窄的地区，
band of extremely hospitable temperate climate. The refrigerator and the general preference for hermetically sealed houses made the California cooler somewhat obsolete, so most of them were removed or retrofitted into boring old regular cabinets. But for a while anyway, the East Coast had its barters, the Midwest made great use of its sellers, and California had coolers. After I discovered my California cooler, this simple, regional architectural feature charmed me to no end. So as we were approaching our 500th episode, the folks here on staff started thinking about the kinds of designs that we love from the places we have lived, and even some regional vernacular that we love from places we haven't lived, but just admire.
它们在保持食物冰凉方面相当有效。冰箱以及人们对严密密封房屋的普遍偏好，让加州冷却柜在某种程度上被淘汰了，因此它们大多被拆除或改造成了无聊的普通旧橱柜。但不管怎样，东海岸曾有它的冰窖，中西部充分利用了它们的地下室，而加州则拥有冷却柜。在我发现我家的加州冷却柜后，这种简单、具有地方特色的建筑元素让我深深着迷。因此，随着我们即将迎来第 500 期节目，工作室的伙伴们开始思考，我们深爱哪些来自我们生活过的地方的设计，甚至包括一些我们没住过、但仅仅是极其欣赏的地区性乡土建筑。
99% of Israel is all about who we are through the lens of the things we build. And on this milestone of an episode, the 99PI staff and some friends of the show have stories not only about how we as humans shape the built world, but how specific bits of the built world have shaped us. These are our love letters to the built world. At first, is Vivian Leigh. If I asked you to name an iconic structure that captures the city of Los Angeles and a nutshell, you have a lot of options to choose from. The Hollywood sign,
《99% Invisible》的核心，是通过我们建造的事物来展现我们的身份。在这个具有里程碑意义的节目中，99PI 的员工和节目的几位朋友带来了一些故事，不仅关乎我们人类如何塑造建筑环境，也关乎建筑环境中的特定部分如何塑造了我们。这些是我们写给建筑环境的情书。首先出场的是薇薇安·李。如果我让你说出一个能完美概括洛杉矶这座城市的标志性建筑，你会有很多选择。
perched on the hills and somehow shining through the smog probably jumps to the front of your mind. That was just amazing branding. Or you may think of the Santa Monica Pier if you're a tourist who came for the sunshine and the hashtag vibes. Maybe it's Dodger Stadium if you're a sports fan. It's even possible you'll think of that futuristic arched tower at LAX, if you're a psychopath. But for me, as someone who for years
好莱坞标志矗立在山丘上，在雾霾中隐隐闪烁，可能会首先跃入你的脑海。那真是一次了然于胸的绝佳品牌推广。如果你是为阳光和打卡发圈而来的游客，你可能会想到圣莫尼卡码头。如果你是个体育迷，也许会觉得是道奇体育场。如果你是个精神病患者，甚至可能会想到洛杉矶国际机场（LAX）那座具有未来感的拱形塔楼。但对我而言，作为一个多年来
loved this gorgeously messy city from within, I think of my former home, the Dingbat. Whether or not people know the name Dingbat, if they've visited Los Angeles, they've seen Dingbatts. Dingbatts are kind of hiding in plain sight, right? They're all over Los Angeles. You see them everywhere. In architecture, certainly in my education, as well as just the profession, had largely ignored them.
从内部深爱这座华丽而又凌乱的城市的人来说，我想到了我以前的家——丁格巴特公寓。无论人们是否知道“丁格巴特”（Dingbat）这个名字，只要他们去过洛杉矶，就一定见过这种公寓。丁格巴特公寓有点像隐匿在眼皮底下，对吧？它们遍布洛杉矶。你到处都能看到。在建筑学界，当然也包括我的求学经历以及整个行业，基本上都忽视了它们。
That first voice you heard is Joshua Stein, and the second is Thurmond Grant. Together, they co-edited a book called Dingbat 2.0, the iconic Los Angeles apartment as projection of a metropolis. If you find yourself utterly confused by the term dingbat, it's basically a type of low-rise multifamily apartment building that typically has about six to 12 units. Most have completely flat roofs, but probably their defining feature
你刚才听到的第一个声音是约书亚·斯坦，第二个是瑟蒙德·格兰特。他们共同编辑了一本名为《丁格巴特 2.0：作为大都市投射的标志性洛杉矶公寓》的书。如果你对“丁格巴特”这个词感到无比困惑，它基本上是一种低层多户公寓楼，通常有大约 6 到 12 个单元。大多数公寓都有完全平坦的屋顶，但它们最显著的特征
is their tuck under parking. This basically means that on one side of the building, their parking spaces carved out of the building, their parking space is carved out of the first floor with units behind and on top. This soft story, combined with the modern flat roof, makes the structure look like a box propped up on skinny stilts from certain angles. Like it's this box that floats there and then in the case of dingbat, you just decorate that. You can find this type of housing scattered in different parts of North America, but LA is famous for its dingbats.
大概是底部的嵌入式停车位。这基本上意味着在建筑的一侧，停车位是从一楼掏空出来的，后面和上方都有住宅单元。这种低矮的底层架空结构，加上现代化的平屋顶，从某些角度看，让整栋建筑看起来就像一个靠着细长支柱撑起来的盒子。就像是一个悬浮在那里的盒子，而在丁格巴特公寓的情况下，你只需对那个盒子进行装饰。你可以在北美洲的不同地区零星地找到这种类型的住房，但洛杉矶以其丁格巴特公寓而闻名。
In 1971, the architectural historian Rainer Bannum even wrote that dingbats were, quote, the true symptom of Los Angeles's urban id, trying to cope with the unprecedented appearance of residential densities too high to be subsumed within the illusions of homestead living. These apartments arose in the 1950s and 60s and were a fascinating approach to scaling up Southern California. They somehow delivered both sprawl and density in the midst of an enormous population boom.
1971年，建筑史学家雷纳·班纳姆甚至写道，丁格巴特公寓是“洛杉矶城市本我的真实症状，试图应对前所未有的高密度住宅的出现，而这种密度太高，无法被纳入宅基地生活的幻觉中”。这些公寓兴起于 20 世纪 50 和 60 年代，是南加州规模化发展的一种迷人尝试。在人口空前暴增的时期，它们不知何故兼顾了城市蔓延与高密度。
This is the mid-century, this is post-war, right? And so, the exuberance of the post war years. You know, there was an influx of people just moving to Southern California. So there was an obvious need for housing. And you know, that everybody moving to California, a lot of them were also pursuing this California dream, where everybody imagines that they're going to be living in a single family house. But of course, a single family home for every single person flocking to Southern California
这是世纪中叶，这是战后时期，对吧？因此，战后岁月里充满了蓬勃朝气。你知道，当时有大量人口涌入南加州。因此，对住房的需求显而易见。你知道，每一个搬到加州的人，其中许多人也在追求这种加州梦，每个人都想象着自己将住在单户独立住宅里。但当然，为每一个蜂拥至南加州的单户提供独立住宅
was impossible. So you know, they get the next best thing, or they kind of get the single family home light. You could pull into the carport of your dingbat, and if you squint it, it almost felt like you had your own personal driveway. And unlike with larger apartment buildings, the corridors of a dingbat were all exterior, so you'd walk right up to your front door
是不可能的。所以你知道，他们得到了次优选择，或者说他们得到了“单户住宅的轻量版”。你可以把车开进丁格巴特公寓的车棚，如果你眯起眼睛，它几乎感觉就像你拥有了自己的私人车道。而且与大型公寓楼不同，丁格巴特公寓的走廊全都是外露的，所以你可以直接走到你的前门，
almost as if it was your own house. It was like two thirds of the California dream. But the important thing about dingbats was that they made the most out of their real estate. DingBats were a design that allowed developers and mom and pop landowners to tear down a single family home and build up multifamily housing on that same lot. So these buildings were just big enough to increase density without totally disrupting the residential feel of a neighborhood.
几乎就像那是你自己的房子一样。这就像是三分之二的加州梦。但丁格巴特公寓最重要的一点是，它们最大限度地利用了房地产。丁格巴特公寓是一种允许开发商和夫妻店房东拆除单户住宅，并在同一块土地上建造多户住宅的设计。因此，这些建筑的规模恰到好处，既提高了人口密度，又没有完全破坏街区的住宅氛围。
The DingBat actually did an amazing job of densifying the city, while still maintaining some character of what we understood to be Los Angeles. These apartments were starter homes for a lot of people because of their affordability. They were made quickly and efficiently using inexpensive materials like Stucco and prefabricated aluminum window frames. So it became this sort of preferred model to accommodate the rush, and it was just kind of like figured out how to do it as efficiently as possible
丁格巴特公寓在提高城市密度的同时，仍然保留了我们所理解的洛杉矶的一些特色，这方面它们做得非常出色。由于价格实惠，这些公寓成为了许多人的第一套住房。它们使用灰泥和预制铝窗框等廉价材料，快速而高效地建造起来。因此，它成了一种首选模式，以适应涌入的人潮，并且就像是以尽可能最高效的方式弄清楚如何做到这一点，
using all these sort of tricks. But their simple construction did result in a certain amount of sameness. In a given neighborhood, you would see the same repetitive cuboid structures again and again and again, with the exception of course of the facades. The beauty is that the distinction becomes in the stylization of the facade. The facades were an attempt to differentiate
使用了所有这些小技巧。但它们简单的结构确实导致了一定程度的千篇一律。在一个特定的街区里，你会一遍又一遍地看到相同的重复立方体结构，当然，立面除外。美妙之处在于，区别在于立面的风格化。立面是一种试图将
winding that from another, and the aesthetics were truly the embodiment of mid-century kitsch. A lot of them were decorated with modern abstract decals like starbursts as an homage to the space age. It was also pretty common for the front of the buildings to feature a name that tried to evoke sophistication but really read more like budget vacation. There's all these references to say exotic you know fantasies of like traveling abroad or something like that or like the Sahara or the tropics. There is the Riviera or the Casablanca or the Capri or the Beverly Capri or the Lido Capri.
这栋丁格巴特公寓与另一栋区分开来的尝试，而美学则真正体现了世纪中叶的审丑趣味（kitsch）。许多公寓都用星爆等现代抽象贴花进行了装饰，以此向太空时代致敬。建筑正面采用一个试图唤起人们对精致生活向往、但实际上读起来更像是预算有限的度假村的名字，这也相当普遍。这里有各种各样的参考，比如异国情调的幻想，比如去国外旅游或类似的地方，或者像撒哈拉沙漠或热带地区。有里维埃拉（Riviera），有卡萨布兰卡（Casablanca），有卡普里（Capri），有贝弗利卡普里（Beverly Capri），还有丽都卡普里（Lido Capri）。
There's this building called the Crepe spelled C-R-A-P-I. There are a lot of dingbats that might be called the Capri. So it's a playoff of that, but it's also sort of like the dingbat is becoming self-aware. In the family tree of architecture, if the Victorian home is your stuffy, conservative aunt, and the California contemporary is your cool cousin who studied abroad in Spain, the dingbat is like your drunk uncle who shows up to Thanksgiving in a colipso shirt and dockers. Like, what are they? They've got these varied facades, but they're really just the same building.
有一栋大楼叫“Crepe”，拼写是 C-R-A-P-I。有很多丁格巴特公寓可能都叫“卡普里”。所以这是对那种现象的一种调侃，但也某种程度上像是丁格巴特公寓开始有了自我意识。在建筑的家谱中，如果维多利亚式住宅是你古板、保守的姑妈，而加州现代主义住宅是你在西班牙留过学的酷表哥，那么丁格巴特公寓就像是你那个穿着卡普里衬衫（calypso shirt）和卡其裤、醉醺醺地出现在感恩节聚会上的叔叔。它们到底是什么？它们有着各种各样的立面，但实际上它们只是同一栋建筑。
They're kind of just considered the dumb stucco box. I am more than a little biased when it comes to this form of architecture. When I moved to LA, I hopped around from place to place for years. But the first time I had my name on a lease, it was a dingbat. It was the first place that truly felt mine. But as a former resident, I can also speak fully to their flaws. Remember those lovely outdoor corridors? Not so fun if you lived on the ground floor like me.
它们在某种程度上被认为是愚蠢的灰泥盒子。说到这种建筑形式，我不仅有点偏心。当我搬到洛杉矶时，我多年来一直在各个地方搬来搬去。但我的名字第一次出现在租赁合同上时，那是一栋丁格巴特公寓。那是第一个真正让我觉得属于我的地方。但作为一个前居民，我也能完全说出它们的缺点。还记得那些可爱的户外走廊吗？如果你像我一样住在底楼，那就一点也不好玩了。
There are so many people walking by all day that lucky loose could stare right through my prefabricated aluminum-framed window and into my living room. I had to keep the shades closed at all times, so my apartment quickly became a houseplant graveyard from the lack of natural light. And that unique tuck under parking, it turns out that the thin columns holding up the building above, well, they caused a not insignificant vulnerability to seismic activity, which is a little concerning when you live in a city famous for seismic activity, which is a little concerning when you live in a city famous for seismic activity.
整天都有很多人走来走去，幸运儿们可以直接透过我那带预制铝窗框的窗户直视我的客厅。我不得不时刻拉紧窗帘，由于缺乏自然光，我的公寓很快就成了室内植物的墓地。至于那个独特的嵌入式停车位，事实证明，支撑上方建筑的细柱子，对地震活动有着不可忽视的脆弱性，当你住在一个以地震活动闻名、不，当你住在一个以地震活动闻名的城市里时，这确实有点令人担忧。
And the efficient and inexpensive material used to construct these buildings, well, it wasn't the best at soundproofing. You could literally hear everything. These are significant critiques. Of course, we can understand why somebody would have a problem with the thing that both were basically, but that also as a living experience.
而且用来建造这些建筑的高效且廉价的材料，说实话，在隔音方面并不是最好的。你 literalmente（字面意思）可以听到一切。这些都是沉重的批评。当然，我们可以理解为什么有人会对这种建筑既作为公寓、也作为生活体验本身而产生问题。
They were cheap, they were tacky, and when zoning regulations and building codes phased them out of production, not many people batted an eye. Even the people who defend them have a hard time justifying their preservation. I think we both can see both sides of it it and I don't think either one of us would advocate for all things that's being saved at all costs. You know, there are a lot of copyrights out there and even some crappy ones. But still, there's a lot to love and a lot to learn from dingbats. They helped make a seemingly inaccessible city
它们很便宜，很俗气，当区划条例和建筑规范将它们淘汰出局时，没有多少人眨一下眼睛。即使是那些为它们辩护的人，也很难证明将其保护起来是合理的。我想我们双方都能看到事情的两个方面，而且我认为我们俩都不会主张不惜一切代价拯救所有的丁格巴特公寓。你知道，外面有很多版权，甚至还有一些糟糕透顶的建筑。尽管如此，丁格巴特公寓还是有很多值得爱和学习的地方。它们帮助把一个看似高不可攀的城市
a little more accessible to hundreds of thousands of residents. And yes, they may look like they were designed by a 13-year-old in Minecraft, but as we're all taught from childhood, it's what's on the inside that counts. You know, 50, 60 years later, who's living in dingbats?
变得对数十万居民而言更加触手可及。是的，它们看起来可能是由 Minecraft 里的 13 岁小孩设计的，但正如我们从小就被教导的那样，内在美才是最重要的。你知道，50、60 年代之后，谁还住在丁格巴特公寓里？
Well, it's actually incredibly diverse. What is the range of different family structures, roommate scenarios, immigrants from where, and it's pretty amazing just the slice of life of Los Angeles that you have. How it reflects the makeup of the greater in the ding bag. My ding bag apartment was like a shell that I eventually outgrew. These buildings weren't built to last. They were built to give people like me a start. And when I look back on my time there, I'm flooded, not just with nostalgia, but gratitude. I wish I had fully appreciated that apartment while I was living through this phase of my life. It's the place where I got to try adulthood on for size.
嗯，实际上它们极其多元。不同的家庭结构、室友组合、来自哪里的移民，其范围之广，而且洛杉矶的生活百态就浓缩其中，这相当神奇。它反映了丁格巴特公寓里更广泛群体的构成。我的丁格巴特公寓就像是一个我最终超越了它的外壳。这些建筑不是为了永恒而建的。它们是为了给像我这样的人提供一个起点而建的。当我回想起在那里的时光时，我涌上心头的不仅是怀旧，还有感激。我真希望自己在经历人生的这个阶段时，能充分欣赏那间公寓。那是让我初尝成年滋味的地方。
My then boyfriend became my fiance in the living room of that dingbat. He's my now husband, and we tend to reminisce about that old apartment a lot. We wonder who's living there now, if they figured out how to keep their houseplants alive. If they ever got that squishy part of the bathroom linoleum checked out,
我当时的男友在那间丁格巴特公寓的客厅里成为了我的未婚夫。他现在是我的丈夫，我们经常怀念那间老公寓。我们想知道现在是谁住在那里，他们是否弄清楚了如何让室内植物保持生命力。他们是否检查过浴室油毡地板上那个软绵绵的部位，
where will they go next? And when they're gone, will they miss that dumb, stucco box as much as we do. So, Alexander Laine, tell me about the first piece of architecture you ever really loved. It was very small, about 13 inches by 9 inches. It was the Fisher Price Play Family A-Frame, which is this adorable dollhouse that has a turquoise, shingled, a-frame roof. And when you move the handle on the top, you can fold down the side and get to the inside of the dollhouse and the folded-down part of the roof becomes a patio and it has a sticker on it
他们的下一站会去哪里？当它们消失时，他们是否会像我们一样深深怀念那个愚蠢的灰泥盒子？那么，亚历山大·莱恩，跟我讲讲你真正爱上的第一件建筑作品吧。它非常小，大约 13 英寸乘 9 英寸。那是费雪牌（Fisher Price）“游戏家族”A型屋（Play Family A-Frame），这是一个非常可爱的玩具娃娃屋，有一个绿松石色的、带木瓦的 A 型屋顶。当你移动顶部的把手时，你可以把侧面折叠下来，进入娃娃屋的内部，而折叠下来的屋顶部分就变成了一个露台，上面贴着一张贴纸，
that shows flagstones. It's a. It's such a clever design. It really is. I mean, it's just, it's so smart. For anyone who doesn't know what an A-frame is, just picture a big capital letter A triangles on the front and the back. And it's got essentially no sidewalls. So the steeply slope roof basically goes all the way to the ground. So did your love of this A-Frame dollhouse
上面画着石板。这是一个如此巧妙的设计。真的是这样。我的意思是，这太聪明了。对于任何不知道什么是 A 型屋的人来说，想象一个大写的字母 A，正面和背面都是三角形。它基本上没有侧墙。因此，陡峭倾斜的屋顶几乎一直延伸到地面。那么，你对这个 A 型娃娃屋的喜爱，
translate to a love of A-Frames in the real world? I do love A-Frames. I mean, I was already familiar with them because my grandparents build a ski house in Vermont in the late 1940s in an area where there are a lot of little A-Frframe villages for people to rent for skiing. They like to call them shellays and charge more money, but a-frames really aren't Swiss at all. If you look at Swiss mountain houses, they have a
是否转化为了对现实世界中 A 型屋的热爱？我的确很喜欢 A 型屋。我的意思是，我早就对它们很熟悉了，因为我的祖父母在 20 世纪 40 年代末在佛蒙特州建了一座滑雪屋，那里的一个地区有很多供人们租用去滑雪的小 A 型屋村庄。他们喜欢把它们叫做“小木屋”（chalets）并收取更多费用，但 A 型屋其实一点也不瑞士。如果你看看瑞士的山间住宅，它们的屋顶要
much flatter gable roof. It's still pitched because the snow still has to slide off the roof. But the idea that the A-frame is some Swiss architecture that has been imported to Vermont is just completely made up. And so if they're not Swiss, what are they? Well, that's one of the wild things about them. You can find afraimes anywhere. Like there are Polynesian Island longhouses that have an afraim structure. There are Japanese mountain villages
平缓得多。它仍然是有坡度的，因为雪必须从屋顶滑落。但认为 A 型屋是某种进口到佛蒙特州的瑞士建筑的观点完全是凭空捏造的。那么，如果它们不是瑞士的，它们是什么？嗯，这是它们最奇妙的地方之一。你在任何地方都能找到 A 型屋。比如有些波利尼西亚群岛的长屋就采用了 A 型屋结构。有些日本山村
that have afraim structures. And you'll even see them in kind of desert climates like Palm Springs, where usually they have white walls and are kind of bleached out as if you've left your afray mount in the sun for too long. Attent is really an afray. It's such an easy way to create shelter that you see them in basically any country that has a lot of rain or a lot of snow
也采用了 A 型屋结构。你甚至会在棕榈泉这样的沙漠气候中看到它们，在那里，它们通常有着白色的墙壁，并且被晒得褪色，就像你把 A 型屋的模型放在太阳底下暴晒了太久一样。帐篷其实就是一个 A 型屋。搭建避难所有多么简单，以至于你在任何雨雪交加、
or a need to put up a kind of quick and dirty structure. So part of the thing that interests me is that you can dress up your a-frame to kind of suit whatever narrative you're trying to promote. So Vermont trying to kind of upscale itself with these ski chalets, like when in one direction with the a a frames, they're usually dark wood and they'll have these white gingerbread balconies. But there are a lot of a frames that are more of a log cabin wilderness a frame and you see like the big chunky logs sticking out of the end under the a frame roof. Yeah, it seems that they're common denominator, at least here in the US, is that they're second homes. Yeah. The rise of the A-frame really corresponds to the rise of vacations in the US.
或者需要快速搭建简易建筑的国家都能看到它们。所以让我感兴趣的一点是，你可以装饰你的 A 型屋，以迎合你试图宣扬的任何叙事。比如佛蒙特州试图通过这些滑雪小木屋来提升自己的档次，当朝某个方向发展时，A 型屋通常是深色木头的，并带有白色的生姜饼式（gingerbread）阳台。但也有很多 A 型屋更像是原木小屋风格的荒野 A 型屋，你可以看到粗大的原木从 A 型屋屋顶下方的端部凸显出来。是的，它们的最大公约数，至少在美国这里，似乎是它们都是度假屋。没错。A 型屋的兴起确实与美国度假风潮的兴起相对应。
And in the postwar era, people had so much more disposable income. And there was so much road building. So people were going to new places to go on vacation, and they needed a really simple house that could be built from a kit to take their vacation in. And the A-Frame was the ideal version of that very simple structure. And actually a lot of like wood companies
在战后时代，人们的可支配收入大大增加。而且道路建设也十分繁荣。因此，人们前往新的地方度假，他们需要一栋可以从套件（kit）组装起来的非常简单的房子来度过假期。而 A 型屋正是这种非常简单结构的理想版本。实际上，很多木材公司
came up with A-Frame kits to sell their product. So you could buy the Douglas Fir Association a frame kit and build it on the new lake. Like when you think about a kit house, like the Fisher Price House is the same thing. You can just like pick it up and put it anywhere. And so why is it not that suitable for living in all the time? Like why is it mainly evocational? The principal reason is that when you're inside an A-frame, everyone has to be together all the time.
都推出了 A 型屋套件来销售他们的产品。所以你可以购买道格拉斯冷杉协会（Douglas Fir Association）的 A 型屋套件，把它建在新的湖畔。就像你想到预制配套房屋（kit house）一样，费雪牌玩具屋也是一回事。你只需把它拿起来，放在任何地方。那么，为什么它不那么适合一直居住呢？为什么它主要用于度假？主要原因是，当你身处 A 型屋内部时，每个人都必须无时无刻不在一块儿。
I was actually talking about doing this piece with my 11-year-old and he agrees that A-frames are very cool. But he immediately said, yeah, but you know, it's like everyone has to play the board game when you're in A-Frame because they're basically one big room and then, you know, usually with glass filling in the triangle and then they'll have a mezzanine in the back for the bedrooms. But there's really no privacy. Like you wouldn't want it to be your house all the time. You want to be in an A-frame when you're on vacation with your family and all there is to do is swim in the lake, hang you just have peace and nature and of you.
我其实一直在跟我 11 岁的孩子讨论这个作品，他也同意 A 型屋非常酷。但他马上说：“是的，但你知道的，这就好像当你在 A 型屋里时，每个人都必须一起玩棋盘游戏，因为它们基本上就是一个大房间，然后，你知道的，通常用玻璃填满三角形区域，接着他们在后方设有一个供卧室使用的夹层。”但真的没有任何隐私。就像你不会希望它一直成为你的家。当你和家人去度假、无事可做只能在湖里游泳、闲逛、只有平静、大自然和美景时，你会想要待在 A 型屋里。
Like there's so many different versions of that vacation, you know, it can be on a lake, it can be at the beach, it can be in the mountains. But all of us want that moment of peace and relaxation and it feels like the A-frame can deliver that to you. And I feel like the reason I loved that play family A-frame was because even as a child, I wanted my house to be a little bit more fun. I was at the time when I was coveting my friend's doll houses. I was living in a very traditional Victorian house and Cambridge Massachusetts. And so the A-frame seemed quite exotic to me. And I held on to that love of the A-frame for so many years that when one of my kids showed an interest in doll houses, I actually went on Etsy and bought one, like bought a vintage one. So you got the toy you always wanted, but would you ever get an A-frame that you could actually
这种假期有许许多多种不同的版本，你知道，它可以在湖边，可以在海滩上，也可以在山区。但我们所有人都渴望那种平静和放松的时刻，而 A 型屋似乎能为你带来这些。我觉得我之所以喜欢那个“游戏家族”A 型屋，是因为即使在小时候，我也希望我的家里能多一点乐趣。当时我在垂涎朋友们的娃娃屋时，我住在马萨诸塞州剑桥市一栋非常传统的维多利亚式房子里。所以 A 型屋在我看来相当异国情调。我对 A 型屋的喜爱持续了多年，以至于当我的一个孩子对娃娃屋表现出兴趣时，我居然真的去 Etsy 上买了一个，买了一个复古的。所以你得到了你一直想要的玩具，但你会去买一栋你实际上可以
live in, you know, only for two weeks out of the year? So I love A-frames, and my child that I bought the play family A-Frame for loves A-Frames. But my husband, who is an architect, does not love A-Frames. We were talking at one point about buying some property in Vermont and I said, oh, like this is finally my chance to have an A-frame. And I had this whole vision in my mind of an A-frame for our family and I guess A-frame connected by a deck, like, beautiful vision. And my husband was just like, no, I hate A-frames. What's wrong with that,joy. I think like any good architect, he is more concerned with the practicalities. He just finds them too kitschy, too inflexible, too dark, and that's not really his style.
居住的 A 型屋吗，你知道的，一年只住两周那种？我很喜欢 A 型屋，我为之购买“游戏家族”A 型屋的孩子也很喜欢 A 型屋。但身为建筑师的丈夫却并不喜欢 A 型屋。我们一度在谈论在佛蒙特州买一块地皮，我说：“哦，这终于轮到我有 A 型屋了。”我脑海里对我们一家人想要的 A 型屋有一个完整的构想，我想象着通过露台连接的 A 型屋，那真是一个美好的愿景。而我丈夫的反应却是：“不，我讨厌 A 型屋。”这有什么问题吗，乔伊。我想，就像任何优秀的建筑师一样，他更关心实用性。他只是觉得它们太流俗、太缺乏灵活性、太昏暗，这真的不是他的风格。
So even today, you're denied your dream home. Yes, I'm never going to get my A-frame. Thank you so much, I'll say, I appreciate it. After the break, we join our own Christopher Johnson on the porch. Stay with us. Here's Christopher Johnson. My family's roots are in rural North Carolina. Growing up, I just heard folks call it the country. As in, we're going down to the country this weekend to see your grandma. My great-grandmother, Pearl, lived mostly alone in a small farmhouse on a huge piece of land
所以直到今天，你梦想中的家还是幻灭了。是的，我永远也得不到我的 A 型屋了。非常感谢，我会这么说，我很感激。广告过后，我们将和克里斯托弗·约翰逊一起坐在门廊上。请继续收听。这里是克里斯托弗·约翰逊。我家族的根在北卡罗来纳州的农村。在成长过程中，我只听大人们管那儿叫“乡下”。比如：“我们这周末要去乡下看你奶奶。”我的曾祖母珀尔（Pearl）大部分时间独自生活在一处大片土地上的一个小农舍里，
that's been in the family for generations. It sits back from the country road surrounded by crop fields and swampy woods. Grandma, Pearl and I spent whole summers together. As soon as school got out, my mom would drive me down to the country in her green granada, dropping me off under a massive pee can tree that shaded grandma's house. She'd look down at me and say, I love you, stinky, see you in August. Visiting grandma Pearl was the best.
这片土地世世代代都在我们家族手中。农舍从乡村小路退后，四周环绕着农田和沼泽树林。珀尔奶奶和我一起度过了整个夏天。一放学，我妈妈就会开着她的绿色格林纳达（Granada）轿车把我送到乡下，把我放在一棵遮蔽着奶奶房子的巨大美洲山核桃树下。她会低头看着我说：“我爱你，臭小子，八月见。”去拜访珀尔奶奶是世界上最棒的事。
She made biscuits from scratch that were otherworldly. She kept sweet tea in the fridge, and I loved to hug her. She always smelled like VO5. I spent my days playing in the dusty plough fields, harassing tadpoles and picking apples and bramble berries. At night, dinner, dessert, and probably my favorite part of the evening hanging out with her on the front porch. favorite part of the evening hanging out with her on the front porch. Man, I loved porch time with Grandma Pearl. Back then, my middle schooler life at home was a little complicated.
她亲手做的饼干简直无与伦比。她在冰箱里备着甜茶，我喜欢拥抱她。她总是闻起来有一股 VO5 发乳的味道。我白天在尘土飞扬的犁沟里玩耍，逗弄蝌蚪，采摘苹果和黑莓。到了晚上，有晚餐、甜点，可能还有我一天中最喜欢的环节——和她一起坐在前门廊上闲晃。我最喜欢的傍晚时光是和珀尔奶奶一起在前门廊闲逛。天哪，我太喜欢和珀尔奶奶一起在门廊上的时光了。那时候，我在家里的初中生活有点复杂。
But on those Carolina summer nights, out in the cool breezy zen of that country porch, we just sit in Grandma's metal rocking chairs, listening to the frogs and watching the lightning bugs Things slowed way down for me and I needed that On the weekends neighbors would stop by to say hello to Miss Pearl They'd join us on the porch and spread rumors about recent bear sightings By the way, grandma said moonshineers made those stories up just to keep folks out of the woods and away from their stills. Country people can talk, and there was never a rush. We'd be on the porch for hours.
但在卡罗来纳州那些夏日的夜晚，在乡村门廊那凉爽微风吹拂的禅意中，我们只是坐在奶奶的金属摇椅里，听着青蛙叫，看着萤火虫。我的生活节奏慢了下来，而我正需要这种慢节奏。到了周末，邻居们会顺道过来跟珀尔小姐打个招呼。他们会加入我们的门廊，传播关于最近看到熊出没的谣言。顺便说一句，奶奶说那些私酒酿造者编造这些故事，纯粹是为了把人们挡在树林外面，让他们远离他们的蒸馏器。乡下人很会聊天，而且从来不急躁。我们会在门廊上待上好几个小时。
They called it visiting, like church or the market or walking through town. The porch was the space to get news and to gossip. Of course, you can find front porches all over the US, but down south, porches like the One-Egrama Pearls house, they've long been fixtures deeply tied to the land. Because the south was for so long, predominantly agrarian, so it fit in with the agrarian traditions of processing crops on your front porch.
他们管这叫“串门”（visiting），就像去教堂、去集市或是逛小镇一样。门廊是获取新闻和八卦的空间。当然，你可以在美国各地找到前门廊，但在南方，像珀尔奶奶家那样的门廊长期以来一直是与土地紧密相连的固定设施。因为南方长期以来主要以农业为主，所以这很符合在你的前门廊上处理农作物的农业传统。
So the porch is part of collective southern identity. As a kid, Jocelyn Donlon also spent a lot of time on her grandma's front porch, doing the same stuff Grandma Pearl and I did, like snapping and shelling pole beans. That was in Louisiana, and it inspired Jocelyn to write her book about porch life and southern culture. My grandmother was always working on that porch. She used to whip marangs out there. I have memories of that. She did a lot of crocheting. She never sat out there and did nothing. So it was for her and outdoor workspace. And for a lot of southerners, it's also a storytelling space.
因此门廊是南方集体身份的一部分。小时候，乔斯林·唐隆（Jocelyn Donlon）也花了很多时间在她奶奶的前门廊上，做着我和珀尔奶奶做过的事，比如掐豆角、剥豆荚。那是在路易斯安那州，这激发了乔斯林写一本关于门廊生活和南方文化的书。我奶奶总是在那个门廊上干活。她过去常常在那里打蛋白酥皮。我对那个有记忆。她做了很多钩针编织。她从来不会只是坐在那里什么都不做。所以对她来说，那是一个户外的“工作坊”。对于许多南方人来说，它也是一个讲故事的空间。
That's partly because it gets hell-a-hot down south. As a space built to keep out the southern sun, the front porch naturally invites people in. Add some rocking chairs, maybe a nice evening breeze, a little something to sip on, and nobody's leaving. Folks are going to stay, and they're gonna talk. The South still is very much an oral culture. So I think that the impulse to storytelling
部分原因是因为南方热得要命。作为一个旨在阻挡南方烈日而建造的空间，前门廊自然而然地吸引着人们走进来。加上几把摇椅，也许还有宜人的晚风，再来点小酒，谁都不会想离开。人们会留下来，然后开始聊天。南方在很大程度上仍然是一个口述文化。所以我认为讲故事的冲动
certainly affected the identity of the front porch. It's this kind of love that's made the front porch such an iconic piece of southern culture. Zora Neal Hurston, William Faulkner, Gloria Nailer, writers of Long Center Front Porches to talk about what's difficult, mystical, and beautiful about life in the South. Southern musicians use the porch a lot too. And what's been called the signature shot from Lemonade,
无疑影响了前门廊的身份。正是这种爱，让前门廊成为了南方文化中如此具有标志性的元素。佐拉·尼尔·赫斯顿（Zora Neale Hurston）、威廉·福克纳、格洛丽亚·内勒（Gloria Naylor），这些长期占据前门廊的作家们，都在探讨南方生活的艰难、神秘和美丽。南方音乐家也经常使用门廊。在被称为《Lemonade》中最具代表性的镜头中，
Beyonce and half a dozen black women, artists, and creators sit posted up strong on a wooden front porch. Others name check the front porch right in their songs. I'm the front porch, I'm the front porch, I'm the front porch. The rain porch. See, you want the front porch in my home. I missed a porch, you gave me a song. The front porch may be the perfect muse, but socially it can also be a complicated space. That's partly because of where it sits.
碧昂斯和半打黑人女性艺术家、创作者气场全开地坐在一个木制前门廊上。其他人则直接在他们的歌曲中提及前门廊。我是前门廊，我是前门廊，我是前门廊。雨廊。看，你想在我的家里拥有前门廊。我怀念那个门廊，你给了我一首歌。前门廊或许是完美的灵感缪斯，但在社交层面，它也可能是一个复杂的空间。部分原因在于它的位置。
This extension of the private home jutting all out into the wide open world. For people you're cool with, it's a space to share, but it can also be used to keep some folks at a distance. That in-betweenness can make porch life really complex, and I saw some of these complexities play out right on grandma Pearl's porch. I could tell how close she was to a visitor based on whether or not they came inside her house, or if they only got as close as the porch. Her front porch might have been wide open, but it was still part of Miss Pearl's house.
它是私人住宅向外延伸、突入广阔开放世界的部分。对于你合得来的人来说，这是一个共享的空间，但它也可以用来把某些人拒之门外。这种“中间状态”使得门廊生活变得非常复杂，我就在珀尔奶奶的门廊上亲眼目睹了其中一些复杂性。我能从一个人是只能走到门廊、还是能进到屋里，看出他跟奶奶有多亲密。她的前门廊可能是完全开放的，但它依然是珀尔小姐房子的一部分。
It's a deeply personal space. Like, it seems like it's public, but it's deeply personal. In his research on the history of black people in front porches, architect and designer Jermaine Barnes has come across plenty of folks who use their porches the same way my grandma did. So think of it from porch as a barrier of sorts, right? It's like it's the force field.
这是一个极度私密的空间。就像，它看起来像是公共的，但它其实极度私密。建筑师兼设计师杰曼·巴恩斯（Jermaine Barnes）在研究黑人前门廊的历史时，遇到了许多像我奶奶一样使用门廊的人。所以，把门廊想象成某种屏障，对吧？它就像是一个力场。
It keeps all the people away who are not supposed to get you home. When it comes to race, these kinds of front porch social rules can get nasty. Some of the black southerners that Jocelyn Donlon interviewed for her book recall white homeowners who refused to let them on the front porch, sending them instead around to the back. And then there's black folks spending time on their own porches. There's a long history of controlling black labor and leisure in the US, and there have been real efforts to restrict, police, and even shame those who wanted to gather and relax on their porches.
它把所有不应该进入你家的人都挡在外面。说到种族，这种前门廊的社会规则可能会变得很恶劣。乔斯林·唐隆为她的书采访的一些南方黑人回忆说，白人房主拒绝让他们走到前门廊，而是把他们打发到屋后。还有黑人花时间在他们自己的门廊上。美国有着控制黑人劳动力和休闲活动的悠久历史，并且曾有过切实的努力来限制、监管甚至羞辱那些想要聚集并在门廊上放松的人。
There's a whole racist slur that I'm not gonna repeat here that specifically attacks black southerners for enjoying their porches. When black folks want to get together and have a good time, a simple front porch can become a very contentious space. And in a way, the American front porch has always been fraught. Its history is rooted in the transatlantic slave trade, and that story starts in pre-colonial Africa.
这里有一个彻头彻尾的种族主义粗俗词汇，我在这里就不重复了，它专门攻击享受前门廊的南方黑人。当黑人想要聚在一起玩得开心时，一个简单的门廊可能会变成一个充满争议的空间。在某种程度上，美式前门廊一直充满了紧张感。它的历史根源于跨大西洋奴隶贸易，而这个故事始于前殖民时期的非洲。
The porch, as an architectural feature, can be linked all the way back to West Africa, and it was seen as a place of commerce where people would exchange goods. When those Africans were enslaved, they brought this building typology with them, drawing on their expertise as they built homes throughout the hot humid Caribbean. And then around the late 1700s, the front porch jumped from the West Indies and to what eventually became the United States.
门廊作为一种建筑特征，可以追溯到西非，它曾被视为人们交换商品的商业场所。当这些非洲人被奴役时，他们把这种建筑类型带了过来，并利用他们在炎热潮湿的加勒比海地区建造房屋的专业知识。然后在大约 1700 年代末，前门廊从西印度群岛跃升到了最终成为美国的土地上。
The Haitian Revolution played a huge role here because it sparked a massive migration to Louisiana territory. And that's where Haitians introduced the shotgun house and its front porch. By the early 1800s the front porch became more and more common throughout the American South. Most people used their very humble porches to do work and to keep cool since porches were
海地革命在这里发挥了巨大作用，因为它引发了向路易斯安那领地的大规模移民。海地人在那里引入了“霰弹枪房屋”（shotgun house，即直筒屋）及其前门廊。到 19 世纪初，前门廊在整个美国南方变得越来越普遍。大多数人使用他们非常简陋的门廊来干活和纳凉，因为门廊通常
often raised up off the ground to allow air to flow. For slave holding planters, the front porch could also function as a dais, which they used to assert control. Slave owners used it as a place to sort of be totalitarian, those iconic images of someone standing there, fucking down to someone else, like that's literally what that vertical dominance allows you to do. The porch is a podium of sorts. Some of those planters became incredibly rich,
建得离地面较高，以便空气流通。对于蓄奴种植园主来说，前门廊还可以充当他们用来宣示控制权的讲台。奴隶主把它当作一种表现专制的地方，那些标志性的画面，比如某人站在那里，居高临下地俯视另一个人，字面意思上，这种垂直的统治地位就是允许你这么做。门廊可以说是某种演讲台。其中一些种植园主变得极其富有，
and they deployed the vernacular form to flaunt their wealth. They had mansions with massive multi-story Greek revival front porches, sometimes with columns. These sprawling or Nate gone with the wind type of fares were also symbols of Confederate defiance. Planta's Tweet Front Porch design to show their faith in the power and the permanence of an economy based on slavery. Starting around the 1860s, Front Porch's began spreading way beyond the South.
他们利用这种本土建筑形式来炫耀自己的财富。他们拥有配有巨大多层希腊复兴式前门廊的豪宅，有时还带有圆柱。这些宏伟奢华、带有《飘》（Gone with the Wind）风格的建筑，也是南方邦联反抗的象征。种植园主采用前门廊设计，来展示他们对基于奴隶制的经济的力量和永久性的信仰。从 1860 年代左右开始，前门廊开始向南方以外的地区广泛传播。
Popular home design books, new building techniques, and a movement in architecture that was focused on nature and landscapes all helped make the front porch super trendy across the country. Slavery and war had helped bring the front porch to the U.S. and it was the end of war that brought on the porch's demise. The housing crisis after World War II meant home construction needed to be fast and it needed to be cheap. Some things had to go and that included the front porch. But what really did the porch in was air conditioning. By the 60s, AC was pretty common in American homes. Why would you sit on a porch in the heat with mosquitoes
流行的住宅设计书籍、新的建筑技术，以及一场专注于自然和景观的建筑运动，共同使前门廊在全国范围内变得超级流行。奴隶制和战争曾帮助前门廊来到美国，而战争的结束却带来了前门廊的消亡。二战后的住房危机意味着房屋建设必须既快又便宜。有些东西必须被舍弃，其中就包括前门廊。但真正杀死门廊的是空调。到 60 年代，空调在美国家庭中已经相当普遍。为什么在有蚊子的炎热天气里还要坐在门廊上，
when you've got an ice cold reason inside? We sat on my grandmother's porch so much because she refused to have air conditioning and it was hellishly hot. She hated air conditioning. In August 2020, during the first COVID summer, I took a trip down to North Carolina. I was desperate for the quiet and the fresh open air. Grandma Pearl isn't there anymore, but her house is. When I pulled into Grandma's driveway,
当家里有一个冰凉透顶的避暑胜地时呢？我们之所以经常坐在我奶奶的门廊上，是因为她拒绝装空调，而且那里热得要命。她讨厌空调。2020 年 8 月，在新冠疫情的第一个夏天，我去了北卡罗来纳州。我极度渴望那里的安静和新鲜开阔的空气。珀尔奶奶已经不在那里了，但她的房子还在。当我把车开进奶奶的 driveway（车道）时，
I could almost see her there. By the well, and her apron and wireframe glasses, waving in the slow Carolina summer heat under that enormous peak entry. I sat on her front porch every night before bed. I'd forgotten how noisy it was, with the bullfrogs and the crickets and all the other animals that grandma could name just by hearing their calls. Of course, I didn't get to sit with her and snap whole beans, or laugh with neighbors stopping by to have a glass of cold sweet tea and visit.
我几乎能看到她站在那里。在水井旁，戴着围裙和细框眼镜，在那棵巨大的美洲山核桃树下，在卡罗来纳州缓慢的夏日热浪中向我挥手。每天晚上睡觉前，我都坐在她的前门廊上。我忘记了那里有多吵闹，有牛蛙、蟋蟀，还有奶奶仅凭叫声就能叫出名字的所有其他动物。当然，我没有机会和她坐在一起掐豆角，也没有机会和那些顺道来喝一杯冰甜茶、串门的邻居们一起大笑。
I got none of that great Southern storytelling that's made the front porch legendary. But out on that country porch that my great great grandfather built with his hands more than a hundred years ago, I did get something else, something that's made this space so special and enduring. I got some stillness and I got some peace, just listening to the Whipper Wheels. We're doing a couple more episodes like this where you're here from many of the people who work on the show in a more personal way. It felt like a fun way for us to celebrate 500 episodes. The way you can help us celebrate is to share your favorite episode of 99PI on social media. It can be a recent episode.
我没有得到任何让前门廊成为传奇的伟大南方故事。但在我曾曾祖父一百多年前亲手建造的那个乡村门廊上，我确实得到了别的东西——某种让这个空间如此特别且持久的东西。我得到了一些宁静和平和，只是静静地听着夜鹰的叫声。我们正在制作更多这样的节目，让你以更私密的方式听到许多参与节目制作的人的声音。这让我们觉得这是庆祝 500 期节目的有趣方式。你可以通过在社交媒体上分享你最喜欢的 99PI 节目来帮助我们庆祝。它可以是最近的一期节目。
It can be from the distant past. It doesn't matter. Or please write a five-star review on Apple podcasts. Maybe even do both. As much as I am proud of having accomplished 500 episodes, I think when a new person stumbles upon a podcast with that much history, it can feel a little daunting. So I would really appreciate it
它可以来自遥远的过去。这都无所谓。或者请在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上写一个五星好评。甚至两个都做也行。尽管我为完成 500 期节目感到骄傲，但我认为，当一个新听众偶然发现一个有着如此长历史的播客时，可能会觉得有点望而生畏。所以我真的会很感激，
if you would help guide people to us in a nice way. Thank you for everything, beautiful nerds. 99% of visible was produced this week by Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, and Kirk Holstad, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, music by our director of sound, Swan Rial, by gram hasha. Delaney Hall is the executive producer, the rest of the team, includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Baroubaig, Lashma Dawn, Sophia Klotzkar, Jason DeLeone, Joe Rosenberg, intern Sarah Baker, and me Roman Mars. 99% of Israel is part of the Stitcher
如果你能以一种友好的方式引导人们找到我们。感谢你们所做的一切，可爱的极客们。本周的《99% Invisible》由薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）和柯克·霍尔stad（Kirk Holstad）制作，由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzales）混音和进行技术制作，音乐由我们的声音总监、来自格兰·哈沙的斯旺·里亚尔（Swan Rial）创作。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是执行制片人，团队的其他成员包括埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯·巴鲁拜格（Chris Baroubaig）、拉什玛·道恩（Lashma Dawn）、索菲亚·克洛茨卡尔（Sophia Klotzkar）、杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeone）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、实习生莎拉·贝克（Sarah Baker），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。99% Invisible 是 Stitcher
and Sirius XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and write it too. You can find links to others to share shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org.
和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分。现在总部设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城区（Uptown）潘多拉大厦北边六个街区的地方。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我（Roman Mars），也可以@节目（@99PIorg）。我们在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上也有账号。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到分享我喜爱的节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。
Congratulations. You have listened to the 500th episode of 99% Invisible. Pupu, puu, puu, puu, puu. From Stitcher and Sirius XM. Pupu! you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
恭喜。您已经收听了《99% Invisible》的第 500 期节目。噗，噗，噗，噗，噗。来自 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM。噗！目前本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。